hello everyone quick note here to let
you know that this
that you're looking at listening to
right now is not the traditional
full-length mindscape podcast episode
that exists you can either listen to it
in a regular podcast browser or
even better you can see a different
video for it
see the link right below to click on it
right away the point being
that uh our old friend jana levin who
was on the podcast earlier
jana in addition to being a physics
professor is also
science curator at pioneer works in
brooklyn which is
an organization that brings together not
only scientists but also artists and a
whole bunch of creative people to do fun
things so we thought that for this solo
episode of mindscape we could team up
pioneer works and mindscape and do
a an actual video so artist azikaway
muhammad
has made a little video background for
you to look at while you're listening
to this episode that i did which is a
solo episode on the subject of time
travel
so this is not that whole thing this is
just a teaser trailer if you like
you can find the whole video below so
listen to this teaser if you like what
you hear
click over to the entire video hello
everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and i wanted to tell you those of you
who have not already heard it a little
anecdote about one of the ways in which
in a very tiny manner i have influenced
popular culture
myself you may have heard of the movie
avengers endgame
you probably have heard of it it's the
highest grossing movie of all time
um and in that movie a prominent role is
played by the idea of time travel
so i'm not going to give away any
spoilers for the movie but there was a
previous movie
infinity war in which bad things
happened and the heroes in
end game want to fix those bad things by
going to the past
so when you want to have time travel in
your movie you have to make some choices
about how it works you know we haven't
seen time travel in the real world so
there's different theories of how it
could possibly happen and at one point
paul rudd who's the actor playing scott
lang aka
ant-man uh he and everyone else are
talking about the ideas of time travel
and paul rudd says so you're telling me
that back to the future is just [ __ ]
and i was actually serving as a science
advisor
for end game many people did i was not
the only one but i remember i was in a
room with the writers the directors the
producers and we were talking about the
idea of time travel
time being one of my areas of expertise
purportedly as a physicist
and i explained why i had bad feelings
about back to the future why i thought
it was illogical and so forth and so one
of the people in the room said
you're telling me back to the future is
just [ __ ] and i agreed and so that
line appeared in the movie
i think i i helped that line come into
existence in a very tiny way
and i think for the most part endgame
did a good job at
time travel it was it was a little bit
hazy on this idea of whether or not you
can affect
the past by going into it but it was
much more respectable and logical than
something like
back to the future would be but you know
i always
it always bothered me a little bit that
line because
i have a an attitude a philosophy of how
you should approach being a science
advisor on movies
um you know it's easy to get a bad
reputation in hollywood as a scientist
if all you do is hear what they want to
do in the movie and say no you can't do
that right
there are plenty of scientists who are
very happy to uh
join the writers and directors and tell
them that they can't do that
they don't really need extra people
doing that so my attitude
is when you get a screenplay or a
detailed outline that already exists
and you're the science advisor your job
is not to scold them or tell them
why they're wrong or give them a bad
grade okay your job is to help them your
job is to serve
the movie tell the best most interesting
story it possibly can
and the way that i find is helpful to
sort of mentally align yourself to that
job that responsibility is to think of
the screenplay
as data rather than as a theory in other
words you're not looking at the
screenplay and going
uh no i don't think that's the way it
would work i don't think that's an
accurate description of reality
that's a bad attitude to have to a
screenplay the screenplay is
in this world what actually did happen
and so a scientist who gets data gets
you know an experimental result and
whose response is
no that can't happen is not going to get
that far right once you
shift your mental orientation from
explaining what can and cannot happen to
oh
this is what happened it's now my job to
come up with an explanation for it
it frees your mind quite a bit and it's
almost always possible
to come up with explanations of how
things can happen so
in my mind a movie that would be the
greatest
challenge to turn into something logical
would be something like back to the
future and it's sort of time travel
let's just say a little freewheeling
when it came to the logic of time travel
which is actually admitted
by uh the writers of the movie they know
it but it's a much beloved movie right
like it served its purposes
narratively so something good must be
going on
and of course time travel stories are
still very very popular
recently ed solomon tweeted uh the
following tweet
over the next few weeks people will have
a chance to watch an exquisitely crafted
physics bending very important filmic
meditation on the quandaries of time
and space and also the much anticipated
tenet
uh the joke of course hears that tenet
is a much anticipated movie by
christopher nolan that was just released
i haven't seen it because it's only in
theaters and we're in a quarantine so
i'm not going to the theater but
apparently
time and space bendiness is a big part
of it ed solomon is one of the
screenwriters on another such movie
namely bill and ted face the music
uh ed was also a screenwriter for the
original bill and ted movies and bill
and ted in a very different
way have time travel as crucial plot
points so
we're not tired yet of time travel
movies and time travel logic it's
important to see
how far we can go in figuring it out
thus
this podcast which will be a solo job
i'm not going to talk to anyone else i
have my own
things to say about time travel i want
to talk about
what time travel would be like like how
it could possibly work
uh what is the science behind it what do
general relativity and quantum mechanics
have to say
about it but then also philosophically
what would it mean
what would it mean for issues of
causality and predetermination
and free will and finally what does it
mean narratively why do time travel
stories work how can they work how
should they work
what is the guide to either
understanding time travel stories that
already exist or maybe
going out there and writing your own
time travel story so
bringing all these different issues
together and all these considerations
is is just the most fun thing in the
world and it's intellectually
uh a gas and that's what mindscape is
all about so
if you're ready let's go
[Music]
you